do you guys remember air power it was
apple's wireless charging mat that
supposedly would let you put any of your
devices down and charge from anywhere
like anywhere that you would put your
devices it would charge them there's a
company called
era who came out with this technology
called free power now they partnered
with nomad who was one of my favorite
companies i use all of their charging
devices
i've covered their airpod cases before
in one of my videos and what i'm showing
you guys today
is something that i think is going to
change the way that we wirelessly charge
our devices
obviously wireless charging is not as
fast as plugging in your device
if you've ever used a wireless charger
before you know the pain
that goes into usually trying to make
sure it's in the precise
area
so let's open it up and take a look and
what's great about this is not only will
you be able to place your devices
anywhere on this charging mat you can
also place up to three devices and
what's really interesting is using the
aria technology which is actually 18
coils fit very nicely into this
minimalist sleek design
it will be able to intelligently direct
the specific amount of power that the
device requires
if you put your air pods on for instance
it'll be able to direct the specific
amount of power to
the air pods and then more power to say
your smartphone
let's plug this in and try it out i
actually already opened this and i've
been using it so i repackaged it up so i
could do an unboxing
this unboxing it's a lie but i can tell
you what
this thing's awesome so it comes with a
usbc cable
you can also plug this into any other 30
watt charger which is great but it does
come with one
supplied it even has all of
the other ports that you would need if
you are international
anytime i travel i always bring one of
these nomad wireless charging mats with
me and i have the one that has a little
apple watch
extension on it as well so you can also
charge your apple watch this doesn't
have an apple watch charging extension
but this will charge
anything that is qi wireless compatible
so any of your smartphones any of your
airpods
anything that will charge with a qi
wireless charger this works with it
and just got a usbc port here in the
back
no it's lighting up it's lighting up so
while this seems kind of simple to be
able to achieve
what this mat is achieving it's really
it's never been done before
so this company as i had mentioned
before is the technology inside of this
and what makes them so special is
because they do have this underlying 18
coil matrix
and they have more than 30 patent assets
for this groundbreaking hardware and
software and magnetics to make all of
this work
so free powers individualized device
communication protocol
delivers the exact amount of power
that's required to efficiently charge
each device
so for example a smartphone might
require 7.5 watts whereas
air pods or the earbuds next to it might
only require 2 watts
so it knows what you're charging and
will give it the right amount of power
i'm talking a lot about this but i'm not
showing it to you
airpods okay let's charge them up
charging uh let's see hmm
note 20 ultra okay
oh charging oh hold on let me uh let's
charge my iphone okay cool
oh it's charging it's also charging so
we have all three devices charging and
what's great about this
is you can put it anywhere
charging charging okay let's just move
you over
okay there we go your chart you guys are
all charging and this is i'm putting it
in the corner as well so it's wirelessly
detecting
where the device is and then sending the
appropriate amount of power and
this was a very interesting stat that i
never even thought about considering
when
you have another wireless charging mat
or any device this goes for any of them
out there
without being used in a 30-day period it
is
giving enough power out while not
charging something
up to 130 iphone charges so that's like
four iphone chargers a day but with this
they were able to make it so much more
efficient that when it's idle i think
the equivalent was maybe two and a half
iphones a month which is a huge
difference
this is actually one of nomads airpods
cases which i absolutely love as well
and it even charges through the case i
love that this has like a nice
leather finish to it they even added
some sound proofing to it so that when
you put your phone down
like it's not like you're not slamming
it on like a desk
i love this i'm so excited about this i
just really wanted to show this to you
guys this is not a sponsored video they
did send me this to check out but i was
really excited just watching the
demonstration
and i love the company nomad era was
featured on shark tank so they went on
there
showing their technology and what's most
exciting about this is the technology
inside of this because this has
such a potential to change the way that
we charge our devices this can be
something that's integrated into hotels
in nightstands
in tables maybe even in the medical
field
you can install something like this in a
car like in a dashboard you can just put
your keys down and it'll be able to
intelligently
realize that those are keys we're not
charging the keys but those airpods that
you also threw into your center console
that's something that we can charge
what's great about the free power
technology stack is that it's remarkably
thin measuring less than six millimeters
so something like this might not have
been possible with the traditional qi
wireless charging coils
because it would have to be so much
thicker than this there's a way you'll
be able to get this all fit into this
small of a device
and be able to charge from anywhere i've
never been so excited about wireless
charging
like this is this is so exciting
i'll see you guys in my next video if
you haven't already make sure you guys
hit that subscribe button and be sure to
hit the bell
and leave me a comment let me know what
you guys think of this cool tech
it's not air power it's free power
you